sar adonis permanent secretary in
swedish academy could you give us a
short introductions with this year's
laureates please listen
svetlana Alexeyevich lives in mint in
Belarusian and she is of course an
extraordinary writer for the past 30 or
40 years
she's she's been busy mapping the
Soviets on post-soviet individual but
it's not really about a history of event
it's a history of emotions she's
offering us it's really an emotional
world so these historical events that
she's covering in the various books for
example the Chernobyl disaster the
Soviet war in Afghanistan and so on
these are in a way just pretext for
exploring and she's she's conducted
thousands of interviews with children
with women and with men and in this way
just hopefully offering us industry a
human being we didn't really know that
much at least not in this systematic
manner and at the same time she's
offering us a history of emotion have
you talked to her today indeed I have
she she was overjoyed when I finally
when she finally understood I was
calling her and her comment was
fantastic
she actually hadn't written prose or
poetry she was written fiction she is in
fact a journalist can one could once say
that you are widened the concept of
literature I think so not only if the
material that she's offering us knew but
she's actually devised a new genre a new
kind of literary genre and that really
speaks to her that's part of her
achievement it's a true achievement so
not just in terms of material
do you have an a personal favorite my
have books I I do the walls
unwomanly phase I think it's called in
English that's the one recommend that
people begin with it's it's an
exploration of the second world from
from the perspective that was before
that ball almost quickly the unknown and
it tells the story of hundreds and
hundreds of women who participated we
were at the front in
the Second World War almost well about 1
million Russian women Soviet
participated in the world in the war and
it's largely unknown history and was a
huge success
Union sold more than 2 million copies a
final question yes if one should start
if one is a common reader which book do
could you recommend well I would
recommend this one book about the female
soldiers and participants in the Second
World War
it's a very it's a touching touching
document and at the same time brings you
very close to these to every single
individual and thank you saudade our
newest permanent secretary of the
swedish academy